He's long been
a well-known mercenary leader
around the world.
Now, Yevgeny
Prigozhin is a wanted
man in Russia as well.
He's often merciless.
Group of fighters
is now pitted against the Russian
military leadership,
and Prigozhin is suddenly Moscow's
public enemy number one.
Vladimir Putin
calling for productions group
to lay down their arms to attack Grozny.
All those who deliberately
chose the path of treachery,
who prepared an armed mutiny,
who chose the path of blackmail
and terrorist methods will face
inevitable punishment
and will answer both to the law
and to our people.
He may now be something of a nemesis
to Vladimir Putin.
But it was his decades
long relationship
with the Russian president
that allowed Prigozhin
to establish his own militia.
The Wagner group Wagner.
Wagner served as a private army,
doing controversial jobs
that often
not even Russia's military could do.
Prigozhin, a former prisoner himself
and self-styled
hard man from Saint Petersburg,
used Wagner to operate around the world.
CNN has tracked Wagner
mercenaries to the Central African
Republic, Sudan, Libya,
Mozambique, Ukraine and to Syria.
Along the way,
Prigozhin enriched himself.
Rights groups have accused Wagner
of horrific violence
like this of Bognor fighters allegedly
smashing the feet
and hands of a Syrian prisoner
with a sledgehammer in 2017.
The man reportedly died after his ordeal.
The images are incredibly disturbing.
Like so many others
attributed to his group.
For many years, Prigozhin
denied the existence of Wagner.
Its work best done in secret
A master of mythmaking.
It was Prigozhin
and Wagner,
who set up the notorious Russian
troll farm
used to spread disinformation
around the 2016 U.S.
presidential election.
But when his
fighters took
to the battlefield in eastern Ukraine
and began
winning battles,
Prigozhin seemed to want
the spotlight vested once.
It should be, yeah.
The dark mode
operation began on October eight 2022
in order
to give the battered
Russian army an opportunity to recover
Our guys stormed this city for 224 days.
There were only Volker
private forces here.
His tactics included
flinging poorly armed
and poorly trained troops
into the so-called meat
grinder of war in Ukraine's east,
suffering a shocking number of casualties
in an attempt to overwhelm defenses
Prigozhin rubbed his victories
in the face of Russia's
flailing Defense Department,
venting his fury at that haphazard ness
and ill planning of Russia's
illegal invasion
and chastising the Russian top brass,
mocking Defense Minister Sergei Shoigu.
We do major items the way
you think
you are the masters of this life.
Yeah.
Don't
you think you can dispose of their lives
if you think because you have warehouses
full of ammunition,
that you have that right
now, the Kremlin's secret
weapon may be its biggest threat.
You're chance to play by your
so.
As you can see there, Wolf,
Yevgeny Prigozhin,
someone who has risen to power
very quickly,
it was quite interesting
because over the past couple of months,
as we've been seeing all this unfold,
this feud between Yevgeny Prigozhin
and the defense minister, Sergei Shoigu,
it always seemed as though
Vladimir Putin was sort of
trying to be the puppet master
of both of them
playing them out against one another.
Well,
now it certainly seems as though
Yevgeny Prigozhin has turned on
Vladimir Putin.
Wolf, as far as Ukraine is concerned,
one can imagine Ukrainians
would be celebrating in this chaos
that's unfolding in what they regard
as the enemy camp, namely in Russia.
Rest of the city that the Wagner group
apparently now controls.
It's a military
important major transportation
hub for the Russian military.
What does it mean
for Russian forces in Ukraine
if that city remains in the hands
of the Wagner group?
And for Ghosn's forces?
Could Ukraine use that situation
to its advantage?
Well, certainly, Wolf, they
would use that
because Rostov on Don
is the location
of the headquarters
of the southern military district
in Russia.
But it also is a huge pipeline,
as you just said, for a lot of logistics.
In fact,
the Ukrainian forces have been trying
to intersect the logistics line.
They go on the M4 and the M 14 highway.
They go into region.
Her Harrison Province,
So when you block those logistics,
you certainly grind down the capability
of Russia to conduct combat operations.
But the other thing is that's interesting
is, yes,
Prigozhin and his Wagner group
surrounded Rostov on Don last night,
but now they're about halfway to Russia,
and they're in their forward
elements in a town called Brezhnev
So that is going to cause Mr.
Putin to say,
I've got to continue to protect
and bring my palace guards forward,
surround the city of Russia
and make sure that this coup attempt,
whatever you want to call it,
if that's the proper term,
doesn't take place,
and that I protect the Kremlin,
Red Square
and you've seen as early as last night
and I know you know this
there were many military vehicles
in Red Square,
security forces
all around the city of Moscow.
So they're very concerned
about extensive operations by Wagner
getting more toward
the capital city of Moscow
and causing more disruption for Mr.
Putin.
We know, General, that
so many Russian troops
have been deployed to Ukraine,
and they're obviously fighting there.
They're fighting the Ukrainian forces
who are now launching a counteroffensive.
Do the or does
the Russian military
have enough troops
remaining in Russia
right now to fight the Volga?
The Wagner forces
they didn't have enough troops
to fight the Ukrainian forces,
and that's part of the problem, Wolf.
So, no,
as Bognor
pulled away
from the front lines in Ukraine,
they left massive holes with now
this new action of actually leaving
completely the country.
And Bognor
focusing their effort
on the Russian government.
There are huge holes in the front line.
But I put a caveat to that
a little bit, Wolf,
because the defensive positions
that that Russia
has been putting in place
for the last six months are still there.
So there are mines and trenches and wire
and Russian forces who probably don't yet
know exactly what's going on
and they're confused,
are still in their defensive positions.
So we're as there might be celebration
by some Ukraine,
I'm sure the Ukrainian commanders
are taking this very slowly,
trying to find
where the new holes are
in the front lines
that have been caused by foreigners
that redeployment.
Back to Russia, if you will.
So the Ukrainian forces,
if they're smart,
are looking for new places to attack, but
they've still got to deal
with all of those mines
that are in the ground
and all the trenches
that have been dug over
the last six months
with Russian forces behind them.
We're told that U.S.
allies, NATO's allies across Europe
right now,
they are monitoring the situation
in Russia very, very closely.
The stakes are significant.
What is the top priority for the U.S.
and its NATO's allies?
Right now, General?
Well, what I'd say, you're right.
General Chris Campbell,
EW.com headquarters, the four star
that's in charge of the U.S.
forces and NATO's
forces,
is watching the intelligence
very quickly.
Where are the lines of Russian forces
moving?
What is happening
in terms of their military capability?
What logistics bases are now opening up
and how can they contribute
to the information
that Ukraine probably already has to say
what is truly happening
and how can you use that in your favor?
But they are also
looking for the potential for more
I'd say just more chaos
from the Russian government.
And, Wolf, what you you know what?
I think some of the David Sanger
sort of alluded
to this during the last hour.
The Russian government
is not a true government right now.
They are a criminal organization.
So you're having a fight
between mafia bosses,
between Shoigu and and Pagos
and Gareth's a mob
and some of the generals
and of course, Putin.
And we can't think of this
as really good decision
making
inside of a government
that's trying to do the best they can
to win a war.
What we see instead is a bunch of capos
attacking each other
in a Mafia,
trying to gain power and more money.
It's been corrupt like this in Russia
for at least the last two decades
and an extreme scale.
And it's going to continue.
And now it's coming home to roost.
The Kremlin,
as you know, has
spoken with the leaders in some
some neighboring countries,
including Belarus, Uzbekistan, Kazakhs,
Is there a concern, General,
that the unrest in Russia
might spill over into other Putin aligned
countries?
You know, Wolf, I'm
going to predict that
that exactly will happen.
And when I was commander in Europe,
we watched that very closely.
The actions inside of Moscow
would certainly affect them,
the actions in places
like Tbilisi, Georgia,
or some of the other stans.
You know,
they have been under Russia's thumb.
They have been under Mr. Putin's thumb.
And, in fact,
many of the soldiers
that Russia has has deployed
and mobilized
have come from those outlying areas.
And places like Belarus,
which is tenuous at best with Mr.
Lukashenko,
are now feeling
feeling
like they don't have
the support of a government
that looks a little bit like it's
starting to crumble and be
and be more dysfunctional
than it already has.
So, yes, I would suggest
having been a reader
of the other countries
associated with Russia,
that this is probably call
it, causing a whole lot of problems
in a lot of foreign capitals right now.